the Iranian president's chief of staff
has said Iran and Saudi Arabia should
work together to resolve their problems
tensions have long been high between the
two countries diplomatic relations were
severed after an attack on the Saudi
embassy in Tehran in 2016 dorsa Jabari
has more from Tehran this comes at a
time when Iran finds itself in a
situation where it needs all the friends
it has in this region this is something
the chief of staff alluded to he said
that there is no reason for Iran not to
have good relations with its neighbors
including Saudi Arabia of course Iran
and Saudi have had a very tumultuous
relationship over the past few years and
it began in January of 2016 when a
number of Iranians stormed the Saudi
embassy in Tehran and destroyed what was
inside because they were angry about an
execution of a Shia cleric in Saudi
Arabia since then Saudi officials have
cut diplomatic relations with Tehran and
things have just escalated since then
given the war in Yemen and a number of
other things that have taken place so
there is a sense on the Iranian side
anyways for now that there needs to be a
close look at this relationship and one
of the main sticking points for Iranians
is the war in Yemen they want to see an
end to that as soon as possible and they
say they are ready to go back to
establishing relationship with Saudi
Arabia as soon as that happens and this
statement we heard from rouhani chief of
staff today just highlights how
important Saudi Arabia is for Iran and
of course in the having stability in
this region